ذروه عمليه اجلاء المدنيين كانت قد حدثت
في شهر اب اغسطس الماضي مع احتدام العمليه
العسكريه ما يمكن الحديث عنه في هذه
المرحله في بخمتها مبادرات خاصه كان لافتا
بالنسبه الينا امس عند الدخول الى المدينه
رؤيه رقم هاتف مطبوعه على الجدران
لكي يتمكن من يريد ومن تسمح له ظروفها
بالخروج من المدينه لكننا نعلم ان شبكه
الهاتف مقطوعه في المدينه وبالتالي قلائل
ومحظون من يتمكنوا من الاتصال وهذا ما حدث
مع ثنائيه كنا قدر رفقناه في عمليه الخروج
من المدينه ذلك ان هناك ثعبان
اضافه الى مساله القصف المستمر على مدار
كل دقيقه بمعنى الحرفي للكلمه هناك ايضا
مساله صعوبه وصول الحافلات احيانا ذلك انه
هناك ضروره لتغيير الطرق التي تصل الى
مدينه بخمود سائقه الحافله التي اقلب هذين
المدنيين امس اخبرنا انه اضطر مثلا قبلها
بيوم الى تغيير الطريق التي يسلكها بسبب
قصف جسر ما ادى الى فيضان المياه والصعوبه
تنقل هذا من الجهه من جهه اخرى من بقوا في
المدينه وكنت ايضا قد ذهبت الى ما يشبه
مركز ايواء هو اكثر مركز انسان يقصده كبار
العمر العجز الذين بكل بساطه لوحدهم ولا
تسمح لهم ظروفهم الصحيه واحيانا العقليه
بالخروج من المدينه هؤلاء يعتمدون على
مبادرات من متطوعين اا في هذا المركز
ياتون لكي يحصلوا على القليل من الدفء
واطعم اذا نعم عمليات الخروج من المدينه
مستمره لكننا لا ننسى ان مدينه بخمود كانت
تعد اكثر من 70,000 نسمه قبل بدء كل هذه
العمليات وبحسب التقديرات بقي فيها بين
2000 وخمسه الاف شخص فقط هذا يعطيك فكره
عن حجم همم الناس الذين تركوها ومن بقي
فيها